invite you to catch the lights for
flights throughout Downtown Summerlin
this season helping create Miracles and
memories
we're here at downtown Summerlin where
we have our lights for flights campaign
we're right here in front of our Miracle
sign in front of Santa's cabin we're
inviting the community to come down take
a photo take a selfie in front of the
signs and donate to Miracle flights I'm
here with my colleague Kathy and she
really is the inspiration behind lights
for flights Kathy tell us why you
decided to do this campaign so I'm the
mom of a special needs kiddo so Miracle
flights provides flights for families
have to travel for medical care and I
have a specialist kiddo and we had to
travel back and forth to Stanford so our
mission is so near and dear to my heart
and when we were all locked down for
covid we just when everything opened up
again we needed to feel the sense of
community we needed to get out and we
needed hope and we needed love and we
needed joy and peace and that's where
and miracles and that's where these
words came from and so it's our hope
that everyone comes out enjoys a life
take photos let your kids play around
with them and enjoy the evening enjoy
the lights be inspired but also give
what you can because the flights that we
provide these families are life-changing
but sometimes life-saving to these
families and the kids that we're flying
beside every one of our signs you're
going to see a poster with a QR code
when you're down here at downtown
Summerlin as you're enjoying the
festivities take a selfie take your
photo and then click that QR code that
allows you to really give back to
Miracle flights and donate as little as
ten dollars you'll see a picture on
every poster in these highlight a kid
that we fly and tell a little bit about
their story and their medical journey
and for instance Miracle has Axel on
here and he flies to San Antonio for
some intensive Physical Therapy
treatment these flights make a world of
difference to these families and to
these kids they are giving kids like
Axel better quality of life he's able to
sit up in his wheelchair he's able to be
more independent it because he's able to
get to that treatment and we want to
thank Sola they really help bring lights
for flights to light without them
without Downtown Summerlin and without
the support of the Southern Nevada
Community we could not provide the
flights that we provide to families in
need our CEO and myself are really
devout aviators in addition to that we
really believe strongly giving back to
the community and Solace mission
statement is to assist those that are
less privileged and maybe don't have the
resources to take care of themselves in
such efforts such as this so This Union
in the in this disability and
opportunity to put these merge Aviation
and Community Assistance together with
something that we just couldn't turn
down and then when we look further and
investigated the background and
especially the the the
everyone that works in this organization
they're so focused on on the outcome and
where we shouldn't be more thrilled to
be so this year for the first time ever
we have a brand new sign debuting here
at downtown Summerlin it's the I love
you sign so if you have a special moment
in your life if you want to propose
something else come down to downtown
Summerlin
[Music]
thank you to Miracle flights for
sponsoring that segment they will be lit
through January 1st for more call
800-359-1711 or visit miracleflights.org